never look
back hacks and simply learn to get ahead
Jess Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University direction true champion who
upskilled to win
big how big a massive height that
transformed my life changed pretty early
in the r and simply learn to get
ahead a civil engineer turned data
scientist decided simply learn from
mechanical engineering to a data analyst
and a podcaster in his free time career
transform simply learn industry
expert data
expert with a well structured course it
felt like a piece of cake recording also
awesome is that long didn't choose a
quick fix he just added data science
into the
mix Nathan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nin from getting ahead what
an allrounder de HOA night with flexible
learning you can always make it right
passion
situ you will find your way to get ahead
when you
simply be starting in few minutes uh
meanwhile let me just introduce myself
so I'm rashak Khan I'm your host for
today's webar and I'm joining all the
way from Bangalore India you can drop us
a hello on the chat here and let us know
where are you tuning in from uh let the
global conversations begin um before we
start uh let's just introduce ourselves
and on chat here and let's let's
socialize Network a bit right these
events are pretty interesting for
networking right so let's just start
here
and introduce ourselves on the chart
here before we start and we're starting
in few minutes uh we already have a
speaker here with us Bernard
Chamis so Bernard where are you joining
us from I am about 20 minutes outside of
Atlanta Georgia in the
states um it's a little chilly so that's
why I have on
my
uh I can see Debra has written her name
but would love to know where are you
joining us uh I can see Guru has joined
from rupnagar Punjab I can see princess
has joined from Bali and uh Mohammad
ashra again from Chennai chetna from
bopal I can see krishnakant from Pune I
can
see Nandita from
Poland and Raj has joined from Mumbai so
awesome
keep the introductions coming in for
once again so
I all the way from Bangalore
India you can see folks are introducing
themselves letting us know them name and
where they're joining
from because it's a good place to have a
global
conversation I can see Julian has joined
from
Chicago us from Nigeria from us zah from
Pakistan and many more introductions
coming in so that's great uh so we'll be
starting the session a few minutes
meanwhile uh let me just quickly take
you through the ground rules here so we
have a few ground rules for the session
uh all you need to do is you need to put
on your questions in the Q&A box if you
have any questions for our speaker here
today uh who who has already joined us
Jus and uh in case basically uh you are
putting down your questions from the
chat box we
might I love to address all of your
queries so you can put down your
questions in the Q&A box and also keep
it related to digital marketing because
today's topic is uh regarding digital
marketing careers in 2024 so and uh the
session is being recorded so in case you
want to go through the recording of the
session again uh you can expect a
followup email with the recording link
and the webinar certificate and also the
bonus offer for attend attending this
webinar for the program enrollment and
to request to approve of attendance for
this webinar you can provide your full
name in the post webinar survey which
you'll be getting over mailed once the
webinar is done so the duration for this
webinar 60 Minutes uh and this uh
webinar this program is powered by
simply learn world's number one online
boot
camp uh here we're very proud that we
have been in the skills training space
for almost 13 years and uh we have uh
Advanced careers for almost 5 lakh plus
people in over 150 plus countries uh we
have 800 plus qualified trainers and we
have categories of courses globally uh
of AI machine learning data science
business analytics cyber security
project man management digital marketing
which we are going to cover today and
many more like that so moving on so uh
today's agenda for the webinar here uh
we'll be talking about digital Mark
marketing careers in 2024 but before
that we will be getting to know you a
little better as well you know how we
can help you out in your digital
marketing career so and also Bic will be
talking about the what the this program
offers and by part University and uh how
this program gets you job ready and
we'll be taking you through the
enrollment step steps of the program and
also there will be a special duration
for the Q&A part towards the end of the
program uh but in case uh we have time
in between we'll take as many questions
as possible throughout the session also
so uh if you have put down your
questions in the Q&A box so don't worry
just have a little patience we we'll try
to address all of your queries so thank
you so much so uh as I mentioned that
we'll start by getting to know you a
little better so uh you can see a quick
pool launched right now so we would love
to know how many years of experience do
you currently have so you can see four
options here the first one being less
than two years second one two to five
years third one 6 to 10 years uh and the
last one more than 10 years so you can
uh basically select the option which is
more suitable for you and uh I'll just
give 10 seconds more for the poll as of
was speaking folks have already started
sharing the response of the go so that's
great we've gotten really active
audience here and and aspiring set of
Learners uh yes spple uh we'll be you
will be getting uh the basically webinar
certificate for attending this webinar
for that you need to stay toward till
the end of the webinar and uh you have
to fill in your full name in the post
webinar survey so uh
yes I think just to clarify I'll just
put that on the chat here for folks who
have questions about the certificate and
and the recording uh basically recording
of the session as
well uh that that will be after the
webinar
ends awesome I think most of the folks
have already shared the responses on the
quick poll here about how many years of
experience do you currently have so let
me just uh give five seconds more for
the poll here for folks who are still
sharing the responses so 5 4 3 2 1
let me quickly end the
poll and also share the results with you
folks okay as we can see that uh 53% of
the folks have less than two years of
experience uh 21% of the folks have 12
to five years of experience 12% of the
folks have 6 to 10 years of experience
and 14% of the folks have more than 10
years of experience so we have gotten
folks from uh almost every set of
experiences you know here so it's it's
good to good to see you folks uh again
like thank you so much for sharing that
with us and uh we'll move on uh with our
speaker here today who joined us Berard
Chambers we'll be taking you through
this free master class uh Berard first
of all welcome thank you for taking the
time out uh for this webinar uh we would
love to know your introduction um please
go
ahead yeah absolutely uh this picture is
so funny because it looks much different
than the one that's on the first slide
so they think like it's three different
people but again my name is bernardet
Chambers I have been teaching digital
marketing now for a total of about 10
years um I started in this industry in
2012 um and am now working as a uh as a
digital marketing trainer for
enture um which is really really uh
remarkable because I get to work
directly with the platforms but most of
the things that I learned I had to learn
themselves taught because at the time
there were not programs like this that
were built for learning you kind of had
to go through the platforms and their
webinars and all of this to kind of sort
these things out but as technology has
changed more and more universities
thought it not robbery to build programs
like this and so it is really remarkable
to see the evolution of this industry
and that they're creating programs like
this just for you all so glad to be here
to provide my insight and to help you
guys navigate this amazing
field
uh thank you so much Berard for a
introduction once again welcome uh and
we'll be starting with about careers in
digital marketing in 2024 so uh let's
start with the first slide here so
basically how the digital economy
requires digital marketing can you share
your comment on this yeah so essentially
when we dealt with traditional marketing
traditional marketing was more about
print advertising doing commercials
trying to get the word out about
specific products or Services um in a
very concise way when digital marketing
was introduced what it did was it
leveled the playing field for all types
of businesses so you no longer had to
have this massive budget to be able to
get to your audience now at first it
didn't take a whole lot of wind right
because of you know just people not
being sure being skeptical if it was
going to work and now it is is the way
the natural way of doing business if
you're not doing digital Market
marketing what are you doing right and
of course during post-pandemic we are
definitely relying on digital marketing
more and more so I'll say that
essentially with all of the things
that's going on all of the ways that
even the buyer Behavior has changed post
pandemic digital marketing is where the
economy and where businesses are going
and I haven't seen this industry slowing
down
in fact I've seen it increase uh so that
people can really start to adapt some of
these
processes uh that sounds pretty
interesting uh thank you so much for
sharing that with us uh and also the
skills right the D matter skills which
open up so many career options in 2024
can you tell us a little bit about that
and also while you're telling us like
what would be the most hottest you know
job in digital marketing 2024 you know
people can Aspire for and also the skill
as well you the skill which basically
will be very very much trending in the
next year yeah absolutely so everybody
who is on the call I want you to look at
this slide as if you are in the medical
field right when you're in the medical
field you have a general practice doctor
then you have maybe a cardiologist you
may have a optometrist all of these
different specializations right so at
the very top you have digital marketing
manager who basically manages all facets
of all of the different disciplines or
domains within marketing they need to
know a little bit about how each
function works but not necessarily
everything there is to know right
depending on what your interest is this
is where you decide how to splice out
your career are you interested in
creating content which content marketing
is a huge piece right now more and more
companies are looking for people and
individuals who can not only source
content but create and edit content
you have the email marketing manager who
looking for messaging that will help to
turn clicks into customers or people who
have purchase products in the past
social media strategist because that
role can be automated they're looking
for people who can automate messaging
that will make sense to the audience and
build the audience then of course you
have digital advertising manager and the
difference between the digital marketing
manager and the digital advertising
manager is one is more working in
conjunction with PPC or paid marketing
versus managing the group as a whole you
have e-commerce manager which is huge
right now because as we know post
pandemic a lot of stores closed right
they went out of the B brick and mortar
stores went bankrupt but they still have
their online presence they still have
their online stores so they need people
that can understand the customer Journey
understand the user interface make it
easier for the path to purchase then of
course you have the website marketing
manager which is basically the messaging
so this is not a web developer per se
it's about the messaging the psychology
of buying and then SEO analyst which SEO
is kind of like the the the clutch to
the gasoline right you have a PPC
specialist but the hopes is that when
you're working with an SEO analyst they
are able to optimize websites so that
they show organically in a search engine
and you can ultimately lower your budget
from spending PPC to SEO so that in a
nutshell is all the this different
discipline and when we do these
workshops I tell people once you get a
full understanding of how digital
marketing works then you decide what
really sticks out because this industry
you really have to be passionate in it
doesn't make any sense to do something
just for money if you're going to be
burnt out right find something or one of
these disciplines that you really find
yourself interested in and it's a
lifelong journey of learning there's
always going to be changes in technology
so make sure that you educate yourself
even further beyond the
program uh well that sounds a pretty
interesting and aspiring you know career
for someone who basically wants to take
up digital marketing 2024 uh let's talk
about the skills as well I think we
talked about the career paths here and a
little bit about the skills as well but
let's talk about what skills do you need
to you know up to need to up to dat uh
for digital marketing roles in 2024 here
as we can see there are so many skills
here B uh but do do you need all these
skills basically to to be a digital
marketing expert or we can start with
some you know something uh you know
which is much easier to start with you
know someone coming from a completely
different field not a digital marketing
field yeah absolutely so no you don't
necessarily have to have all of these
skills but depending on the role you do
need to know enough about them to be
able to collaborate with your teams now
I tell people all the time on these
workshops that if you see a job posting
and it has that you need to execute all
of these skills run because it's way too
many skills to try to implement
successfully it's kind of like Jack of
all tra master of none right but
specifically it just depends on the role
and what I would encourage everyone to
do is I would encourage everyone to go
on to sites like LinkedIn and see the
job postings and see what skill sets and
kind of work on the skill sets that you
see that's reoccurring in the role that
interest you most but as someone that's
new just coming in into digital
marketing you don't have to know all the
skills you can choose a few of them and
become a master of
those thank you so much for answering
that uh I think we have talked about the
skills we have talked about the careers
in digital marketing in
2024 so what exactly is stopping you
from becoming a digital marketing expert
so you can see a quick pull your screen
here with the four options here this is
a multiple choice question so so you can
select multiple options here because
there can be multiple concerns right so
uh this with this PO we would love to
understand what is the biggest challenge
you face you know when it comes to
taking a digital marketing career in
2024 so I just read out those options
for you uh as you basically are sharing
your responses on the poll here so the
first one here is I can't find a program
with a fully comprehensive curriculum
second one I don't have the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready
third one I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos and the last
one my work should won't allow me enough
time for learning so uh as I was
speaking folks have already started
sharing the responses on the poll here
so we've gotten an active set of
aspiring Learners here that's
great and uh meanwhile I just give 15
seconds for you to basically share the
responses for the poll here in case uh
these options don't cover your answer
basically what is the biggest challenge
what's stopping you from becoming a
digital marketing expert we can let us
know in the chat or in the Q&A box as
well you know what basically is your
biggest
concern so uh also folks please don't
share your personal details on the chart
here uh so uh this is basically chat is
open for everyone so
please we'll be upcoming next we'll be
talking about what does the p
University's program in digital
marketing covers and how does it get get
your job ready and also gives you the
Practical experience practical knowledge
as
well awesome I think uh most of the
folks have already shared the respon the
Poli yes I'll just give five seconds
more uh so what basically is stopping
you from becoming a digital marketing
expert so let me quickly end the poll in
5 seconds here so 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and share the
results with your folks I think the last
time someone has messed that the poll
was not visible so I've shared the poll
right now uh please do let us let me
know if it's not visible for you on the
chat
here okay uh as we can see uh 68% of the
folks have basically voted for uh I I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready and uh 38% of
the folks have voted for I can't find a
program with a fully comprehensive
curriculum and 28% of the folks have
voted for my WorkOne alarm me full as
you have seen you know a lot of people
who have joined uh basically have uh you
know minimum two to 10 years of
experience so we can understand that and
few the folks have voted for I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos so uh thank you so much for
sharing that with us and once again like
if this options don't cover your
responses you can let us know so now
moving on to the program here so the
program by per University uh
postgraduate program in digital
marketing uh comes with a comprehensive
curriculum with an industry aligned
learning path uh in this program you get
access to integrated case studies
Hands-On projects or practical
experience and also you get access to
online live virtual classrooms with beer
and instructor interaction and this
program is basically flexible to fit
your lifestyle and schedule the program
duration for this one is eight months
and you can just uh give 5 to 10 hours
per week in order to complete the
program uh the program is co-created
with meta blint which will'll be talking
about in much more detail in the
upcoming slides and also the content
provider for this one is Howard business
publishing education uh so U just just a
question B uh the online live virtual
classrooms uh you know what does the
learning environment looks like you know
what is the kind of interaction which
happens between a paer and Stu
up yeah absolutely so the live classes
are where students are able to really
iron out the specific pieces of their
program that uh make sense so these are
the examples that you're looking for the
Practical knowledge that you're looking
for the examples talking about the
concepts in great detail and getting
your questions answered one of the
things that I find about having a live
virtual uh or a hybrid type of
experience is where whatever gaps that
the um LMS has we are able to fill those
with contextual knowledge with examples
and so um I personally whenever I'm um
facilitating a class I interact with the
students inside of the LMS sometimes I
build a Google Classroom out for us to
all have dialogue with one another it's
just one of those ways to keep the class
collaborative and even though the live
classes are for hours we try to make
them as engaging as possible so that you
can get your questions answered and you
can have detailed explanation around
things that you know for sure that you
don't have an understanding
of on that's some pretty interesting
class to be a part of uh and basically
what exactly you'll be getting from this
program you'll be getting a Purdue
postgraduate certificate in digital
marketing as you can see on the screen
here and also you get access to Hands-On
projects a Capstone project which will
be talking about in much more detail in
the upcoming slides uh which basically
will give you that practic experience
you're looking for and master classes
and EMAs with Peru and meta as meta
being one of the partners here and perdu
Association membership we get to be a
part of an interesting and diverse set
of Learners who join basically from
different sectors and also different
companies and we'll be sharing that in
the upcoming slide here so let's talk
about the puu university Advantage here
so pu is a 151 year old University
established by a land grant from the
state of Indiana and it conly uh
basically comes in one of the top public
us universities has produced Nobel Prize
winners so that that's basically very
interesting University Global University
to be a part of and also having P
University on your CV is a prestigious
accomplishment recognized worldwide so
ber just would want to basically ask you
a question like you have basically taken
up so many batches with simply right in
this program so uh what have you seen as
an advantage for folks basically who
don't have a good University or a good
you know alum in their basically
portfolio and they take up this course
how does it change you know it for them
what exactly is an advantage you know
what do you think of other body
University for them yeah absolutely
because digital marketing is one of
those fields where people can work
around the world it is ideal in the
remote World essentially Purdue
University adds that Badge of
credibility for you all to be able to
get the types of assignments that are
really prestigious and really have
meaning behind them and of course what's
important to everybody the pay right so
when you have Purdue University on your
resume not only do you have that on your
resume but I also see that the students
are able to access the Alumni network
and there's lots of people who graduated
from Purdue that work in Tech so
essentially it doubles as your
credibility and your networking to be
able to find um opportunities where you
may have some folks that were Purdue
alumni that may be hiring managers or
decision makers or things of that nature
in addition to that Purdue University
actually does write a large portion of
our curriculum they approve of our
curriculum they kind of go through and
add extra points because like I said
before this is an evergreen industry so
you can't just take a textbook from last
year and apply it from this year I was
kind of glancing at the chat earlier and
I saw people asking about AI if you get
a book from last year you're not gonna
see anything about chat gbt in it so
that's one of those areas where you have
a lot more credibility whenever you have
a university behind you when you're
going up for work
uh that sounds pretty interesting and uh
University you know you would want to
have in your portfolio thank you so much
for answering that uh now let's talk
about the meta Advantage here So Meta
blueprint being one of the partners here
with bird University uh in this you get
access to exclusive ask me anything
sessions by meta master classes by meta
experts uh industry recognized meta
blueprint certification exam prep and
voucher uh and adding to that you also
get job assist services from learn uh
for India and us only uh this is in
Partnerships with IM jobs in India and
talent in in us uh in this you get
resume building assistance uh Career
Mentoring and interview preparation
Services via webinars and career phase
as well uh and the eligibility and
prequisites for this program you
basically can be from a marketing or a
non-marketing background uh you need to
have a bachelor's degree in any
discipline that's okay and you need to
have at least two years of work
experience which is required basically
to join this program so uh so just a
question here Berard for folks who come
from a marketing background and folks
who come from a non marketing background
like what are are the advantages for
folks basically who are coming from
marketing background and someone
basically coming from non-marketing
background do are they able to basically
uh perform in this particular program
like um are they basically highs and
lows you know compared to someone who
already has an experience in
marketing yeah absolutely so one of the
things that everyone really should
understand is marketing is more about
psychology it's more about how the
customer base thinks and being customer
Centric the mechanics of it anyone could
learn if they really would like to learn
now if you're in a marketing background
your marketing background might be more
traditional and that's perfect because a
lot of the foundational knowledge still
applies here it's just digital when
you're in a non-marketing background I
almost think that having a non-marketing
background is of an advantage because
you're green you are more open to
learning like new things and you come in
with the perspective of things are going
to change what you learned three months
ago um you might not be it might not be
relevant to today so it's definitely one
of those areas where it's a lot more
flexible than other Industries because
of the fact that it's Evergreen it's
ever changing and when you get in and
learn you're going to get in and learn
marketing from that point but there's
another point that is sure to come so
that's where you're at an advantage of
entering this
field uh thank you so much for answering
that now moving on how this program
basically prepares you uh and gets your
job ready so uh we'll be taking you
through the live learning environment
here uh so um B you can go ahead and
share your screen as I think I'll stop
sharing my screen and meanwhile while B
is doing that U just to let you know
know folks we getting a lot of
interesting questions in the Q&A box
here and uh we will be addressing them
pretty soon uh so keep the questions
coming in if you have any questions uh
in basically related to digital
marketing careers in general or about
the program please do let us know in the
Q&A box and I did notice like folks a
few of the folks are putting down
questions in the chat box here so as you
can see there are so many messages
coming on the chat box due to high chat
value we actually might miss your query
here so just quickly go you can navigate
the Q&A box just the chat box here
yeah one of the questions that I'm
getting I turned my my camera off just
so that I can uh open up the screen here
for you guys so that we can watch
through the El but one of the questions
that I see reoccurring is everybody's
freaking out is AI gonna take over our
jobs ai ai well the interesting thing is
is I chuckle when people say that
because AI has always been here
artificial intelligence has always been
here what I'm assuming that you're
referencing is chat GPT and chat GPT and
GPT technology in short is coding that
speaks English before coding had to be
done with a series of characters and
things like that now that type of
predictive language can respond to
English so what does that mean for you
guys it means that it still has to have
it still has to have someone to power it
it still has to have someone to feed it
and create the models for it so that's
always going to require a human element
now are
really cool tools and things like that
that are um being created of course
there are there's great tools that are
being created but honestly it is not
something that you have to worry about
getting in and then there's going to be
a ton of layoffs because you're going to
still have to have the human beings to
power it I'm trying to get into my
system my password is not working let me
try this password guys sorry about that
so that I can share my screen and show
you guys the
LMS oh
no I thought I
had changed it a while back but let me
just
see no worries B you can take your time
uh meanwhile folks what you can do is
you can put down your questions in the
Q&A box uh and we are getting a lot of
questions from the Q&A box that's great
uh so meanwhile if you have any yeah if
you have any others Rasha go ahead and
ask them while I'm trying to do this
password
situation sure sure sure sure
I think I got the password let's see I
think it's doing it if there's any other
questions then I can answer them while
we're getting logged in
here uh yes uh I think we have a
question from nand pal here I'll just
put that question for you in the chat
box because there are so many questions
might be hard to find that question so
I'm just putting that for you in the
chat box so Nita is basically saying
that I am a 47 year old had a break from
career for quite some time now and also
I had been into pharmacist uh as my
previous work uh now would like to shift
to digital marketing uh could you share
how my uh LinkedIn biodata should be or
how what could be my biggest obstacle to
get back into job career I think this is
in terms of digital marketing we can
answer
that yeah absolutely so one of the
things that it it if you're concerned
about your age it's definitely not your
age anybody can enter this field but one
of the things that is going to be a
challeng is that and it's a challenge
for anybody really is the
competitiveness of it but how do you
navigate that well you take on projects
there is a site that is called um I
believe it's uh axium I'll have to put
it into the chat but I refer a lot of my
students to the site because no a cadium
that's what it's called aadum I refer a
lot of my students to the site because
once they have acquired their
certificate ific Ates they can actually
go there and take on projects for free I
know that's not I know that's a bad word
but some of them turn out PID but what
it's really great at doing is it's
allowing you to basically get your hands
on projects and start to exercise some
of those skills that you learn and build
up your portfolio so when you're
changing and you don't have to do it for
six or seven months you can take on a
project for 30 days or 60 days add it to
your profile and then simply let any of
the employers or uh you know folks that
you know to say Hey listen I did this
for six months I did this for three
months I took on this project for a
month and ultimately I got the
experience as well as their certificate
plus again you're getting your
certificate from a very prestigious
University so it's like you have your
The Prestige and The credibility and you
have the experience that you're working
on simultaneously in terms of entering
into the field it doesn't matter if you
have experience or not this is a highly
competitive field but the more that you
can demonstrate that you're able to
drive results revenue and growth the
more you'll stand out with other
folks I believe it's called a cadium the
cadium
yeah um yeah I thank you so much for
answering that B I hope n that helps you
with your question here uh also uh I
think yeah we can go through the
learning environment here yeah yeah if
everyone can confirm that they can see
my screen
um I
don't so this is an example of what each
of the digital marketing programs kind
of look like this would be postgraduate
then there's digital marketing
specialist and there's digital marketing
associate just for example say I'll go
to the postgraduate this is the one that
was for Purdue right here and
essentially what you would do is you'd
come in and you would click on you know
welcome to your class you would go in
and this is kind of what that looks like
so your main classes or your self
classes learning classes would be here
and your live class you would be here to
join after you have completed your live
session and your online session you
would receive your certificate and it
would unlock for you to be able to print
now each learning module is going to
have a certificate but you don't get
your produced certificate until you have
completed the program okay now
essentially if you decide to take notes
digitally you can take notes digitally
here and a really beautiful thing about
this is let's say for instance we were
in class today and I wanted to take
notes I can take these notes
right and basically save them so when I
come back hello class I can come back to
the notes that I have
saved and be able to go through all of
the courses where I've save notes this
section here is the community the
community section helps you to stay in
touch with a lot of the forums and a lot
of the people that are in classes with
you or some folks that have taken the
course and have completed it and have
some great Insight so even if someone
does not answer you you can very well go
in and read threads and find out more
information when you're struggling with
a particular subject matter or you just
need some additional um insight as to
what the course is talking about or what
the instructor is talking about next is
the help section this is the help
section here and any time or any issues
that you have you can reach out with
these folks there's also a chat room um
during their regular hours you're able
to get um live chat help but this is in
terms of labs certificates things like
that and usually they respond to tickets
within 24 hours I haven't had a student
yet that hasn't had a really great
experience so this is essentially how
the LMS works and to go from
there
uh thank you so much B for taking us
through the learning environment uh let
me just quickly share back my screen uh
so yes we just
got yeah I stop
sh thank you uh so we just got done with
the live tour of the learning
environment of universities program uh
in uh digital marketing and we'll be
talking about how this program builds
your digital marketing skills step by
step so by can you take you take us
through these steps
here yes and there's been some
interesting updates which I'm really
excited about so you're starting out
with your intro SE uh with your
induction session or your intro section
for Purdue then you're going to talk
about your first step in digital
marketing Journey with creating your
website the digital marketing landscape
then you'll go through SEO sem smm which
is extremely important to understand
when you're getting into the digital
marketing environment and you have your
email marketing mobile marketing and
content strategy which are supplements
content content content is key this is
where a lot of the opportunities are
emerging from what I can see then you
have P paid campaigns and what paid
campaigns do in this industry is they
accelerate kind of put gasoline on the
efforts that you have within a business
so definitely a really great and
interesting course of course like all of
you are asking about AI I AI being um
artificial intelligence um GPT and
things like that and then you're going
to put it all together in your digital
marketing Capstone project so as you
start the program You're Building each
section or each building block to go in
from
there to go all the way into merging
into your digital marketing Capone
project uh thank you so much for taking
us through the steps now the electives
here uh the digital marketing meta
Master Class the f digital marketing
Master Class brand management Advanced
email marketing Advanced content
marketing and advanced mobile marketing
basically these electives come as a part
of the program and they are optional uh
and you don't have to pay anything extra
basically for taking is up to you if you
want to take it um so moving on to the
next slide here the tools and
basically tools and platforms you'll be
learning in this uh course uh as you can
see there are so many tools here uh you
know which you can see on the screen
here but there are so many many more
tools and platforms this program covers
uh so B can you take us to the tools uh
in this program and also you know a a
tool which will be the most trending
tool you know to learn in 2024 as
well yeah so the keyword uh the Google
uh Keyword Planner and Google ads and
Google analytics are all kind of one
bucket um Google analytics is actually
super important because of a lot of the
Privacy parameters that have set out um
a lot of folks are opting out so with
them opting out we need to be able to
see what's happening and we do show you
that in our program of course Twitter or
X ads forever are going to be Twitter I
don't care what they tell me I'm going
to be a rebel and call it Twitter then
of course hoot hoot is for Content
scheduling so this is to help to
automate your process so that you can
focus on strategy then you have Facebook
or meta ads So Meta is going to cover
both your your Instagram and your
Facebook accounts being ads which are
underutilized but they are actually
starting to come um become a little bit
more popular in terms of just how uh
people are
searching click and sem rush and SE
ranking are all SEO smm tools they are
designed to help you to
research um someone's asking what SE
means um it's search engine ranking so
which search engines are ranking at the
top and what keywords are also ranking
so search engine anytime you see SE
that's search engine which a lot of
these terms you do learn in the program
over time I've been teaching it for 10
years so when I see it my apologies I
just automatically say SE or smm because
that's just the lingo so any questions
there feel free to ask me to clarify and
I won't mind then of course LinkedIn ads
which is a different audience and then
YouTube advertising so you get a really
great comprehensive toolkit um in my my
particular classes when I'm instructing
I share over 60 tools for my students to
be able to utilize so it's tools that
are in addition to the ones that you see
to help you to become a better marketer
which as a marketer if you're coming
into this field it is really great to
have a toolkit it's almost like a
mechanic like you need to have like all
of your tools to be able to do certain
thingss and of course covering chat GPT
because chat GPT is my newest baby love
using chat G GPT
so you'll definitely be learning more
about that as
well uh thank you so much for taking us
to the tools and platforms and also the
additional tools you know you'll be
sharing uh in your class as well uh that
sounds pretty interesting to me um as
you were speaking we are getting a lot
of questions we'll be taking those uh
pretty soon here uh so uh let's talk
about the projects you get uh to work on
you know which with real business
implications so I think this is this was
one of the queries we have gotten in the
Q&A box as well that how do we get the
practic exposure you know from this
program so how does it help so you get
to work on these basically real business
applications projects and also capture
talking about after this so as you can
see these are you know a few of the
projects which you can see on the screen
here so the Air France internet
marketing uh managing online reviews
onent Tri advisor uh EO strengthening
the brand uh with oral marketing Yahoo
price search engine advertising and many
more like this we'll be covering in the
uh program uh Al also now talking about
the Capstone project which we mentioned
earlier you get to work on a Capstone
project you can choose from five Bas out
of you know basically reference uh and a
caption project is something you can
showcase to your future employees uh it
is basically built in a way that mimics
real life business scenarios for True
experience so um I just have a question
B for you that how does having uh an
industry project or a caption project
like this one especially uh on your
resume once you're done with the course
uh when you're trying to get out there
get the job of your dreams how does it
help you know someone who does not have
any experience in digital marketing well
that's what I was going to highlight for
those folks that don't have any uh
digital marketing experience it actually
acts as your liaison to show that you
know how to execute the knowledge that's
really what all experience is but if you
don't have it then you need to have
something to show that you can execute
it so essentially the Capstone project
shows your strategic thinking how you
would approach marketing campaign you
need to be able to articulate that which
is what a lot of the additional
workshops and things like that to help
you to get job ready is but I will say
to all of you like even when you're
going for your roles and you're doing
your Capstone projects look at roles
that would help you to get experience
like in terms of what it is that you've
already set out to do using those
Capstone projects to showcase for
example if you're looking to take on a
role with PPC tackling the Yahoo
Capstone project will help you to show
and how you would execute your knowledge
using PPC things like
that uh thank you so much for answering
that and uh let's move on to the next
part so the caption projects you know U
what cap projects you can choose from in
this program so online app tool is one
of the cap projects on fashion domain
for Telecom domain or online for
Marketplace so sorry
uh and for electronics domain you get
online gadget shop to work on as a
caption project and similarly online e
store and mobile app design platform you
know being one of the cap projects you
can choose from so U moving on uh we
have global leaders as program advisers
here uh basically jinle and Brad GIS and
Matt Bailey being one of the global
leaders as progam advisor from
University so they basically make sure
that simply learn is delivering to
asward standards of per University uh
and moving on the past Learners and
their success stories I think someone
has asked about you know what kind of
Learners join the program so the
Learners uh in the previous classes have
consistence of Learners from excellent
organizations and diverse Industries
like information technology bfsi
Consulting and and others as well and
companies they come from Amazon
Microsoft bleay uh LinkedIn Dela Johnson
Johnson BS for go the phone and many
others so basically you'll be getting to
be a part of an interesting diverse set
of Learners you know that elimin circum
membership also you get to access with
per that is something you take advantage
of also we'll be sharing few success
stories of Learners uh from the programs
which from the previous recent cohs so
we can see marelia here basically says
that the instructor was thorough and uh
has explained digital marketing in depth
uh it was very exciting for her to in
the interactive classes that you know
she could take the classes from anywhere
you know someone basically who already
is a working professional you know
someone like that so basically it's very
flexible uh to your schedule which we
have shared earlier you can just
complete it by giving five to 10 hours
per week uh a what here says that uh he
was awarded with a job as digital
marketing manager for one of the jama's
leading advertising agency uh and this
certification was a game changer for him
and allowed him to start his own company
and scale up his business so that is
something you know completely
transformational as well you know after
the program byward here so kin here shs
that shares that she has been with
simply for three years now uh focusing
on digital marketing courses uh the
courses and the platforms are basically
the top industry standard which
basically we have talked about and the
courses are very well structured and
deled by best inclass world experts and
the last one uh last of the many many
which we have we can share here Girish
here basically shares that his base of
learning the digit marketing principles
has helped uh his basically to achieve
the growth hacking approaches that uh
he's basically applying today and he'll
be coming back to Simply Lear along with
his team to get them more knowledgeable
on specific set of courses so these are
the few success stories basically of P
University digital marketing course here
uh now we would love to know uh that
that are you interested in enrolling
into postu program uh by digital
marketing
by Body University here you can see a
quick poll on your screen here uh there
are two options yes or no also just to
mention that uh the program basically uh
also offers you a bonus offer for
because you're attending this webinar
today so we are actually giving a bonus
offer for the attendees here who
basically chose to enroll into the
program and as I was speaking I can see
a lot of interest coming towards the
enrollment here for the digital
marketing per University program uh um
postr program here so meanwhile what we
can do is uh I'll just give 20 second
for you folks to share your responses
the polia I'll just quickly Bross to the
questions here which we can take up uh
and address your queries as
well uh okay uh B we have a question
here from rashan uh there are a lot of
things in digital marketing for people
starting out uh they should start or
what skill or knowledge they should have
before enrolling in a digital marketing
program like this
one so one of the things that I would
say to that yes there's a lot of
different elements of digital marketing
to start you need to start with the
foundation if you've never entered a
program start with the foundation which
is basically learning what all entails
of digital marketing that would mean you
would learn a little bit of everything
then as you start to get to know the
different domains and the different
disciplines of digital marketing you
would then come in and learn um which
specialization that you would like to go
in or which one that you would like to
have a focus with that's the best way
that I find to narrow your playing field
so that way you're not General it is
better to specialize in this field than
it is to kind of have a general overall
unless you're going to be um you know a
digital marketing manager which does
require in some cases does do require a
little bit more experience it's easier
to break into the industry when you have
a specialization versus trying to go
straight into
management uh thank you so much for
answering that B I hope Russ that
answers your question let us know on the
chat or in the Q&A box uh also uh we
will be taking questions now but the
poll is still live so um you can share
your interest towards enrollment into P
University's postgraduate program Marin
and also not to forget uh the skills the
career path you can take up through this
program and also the industry projects
the Capstone project you know which
basically can be uh career changing you
know Game Changer as we have share the
success stories of Learners here let's
take up the next question here I have
shared that with you on the chat here
when because we have part in a volume of
questions in the Q&A box it will be hard
to find so uh this question uh basically
I can't make out the name from the email
ID but I'll just read out the question
here so how does digital marketing tie
in with EI how can we collaborate with
EI to our advantage instead of AI taking
digal marketing jobs away from us yes
absolutely um I mentioned this earlier
that AI still has to be powered by
something and it has to have commands in
order for it to produce so where you
come in is you're already working in
collaboration it is important to
understand how that technology works and
how to generate the best results that is
what separates them in from the babies
with I'm I'm assuming GPT because like I
said AI has been here um AI has powered
Google AI Powers your search engines
that's how they come up with all of the
search results you're speaking
specifically to GPT or generative
predictive text which is basically
coding speaking English so when you
become good at commanding what powers
GPT there's always going to be a place
for you I don't believe that this
industry is just going to become totally
automated why because there's still a
human element in a human condition so
we're not going to have a bunch of
megans running around if that makes
sense like computers taking over the
world like it's not going to be that
because you always have to have a human
behind them making sure that they
optimize properly making sure that they
deliver the the results so I don't
believe that they're going to take jobs
away however if you don't have the
knowledge then you're not going to be as
competitive if that makes
sense uh thank you so much B for
answering that uh please do let us know
if that answers your question because
you couldn't make out the name from the
question email ID which you have given
also rashan says thank you so much for
answering his question as well
so awesome I think we'll just give five
seconds more for the polio so actually
yeah guys one last time so you can see a
quick PLL in your screen where you can
see options of yes and no for the
enrollment question so are you
interested in enrolling into the
postgraduate program in marketing with P
University um like as we were taking
questions uh actually we can see almost
90% of the folks have already shared
their interest like towards yes they
want to enroll and also you don't have
to worry about you know when do you plan
to enroll in case you're planning that
option is available for more than six
months in case you're plan I'll be
asking you that as well you know when do
you plan to enroll so we can understand
when to reach out to you with the
admissions offer thater we'll be sharing
more about the enrollment steps and
basically the program fee and the
schedule upcoming cohorts uh you know in
the next slides to give you a better
idea about that so please do let us know
if you have any questions about the
program in general in the Q&A box we'll
be taking those we'll be addressing your
ques about that and also uh digital
marketing career in
children awesome I think I'll just
quickly close the poll in 5 seconds so
this is last 5 Second for few of the
folks who have not responded for the
poll uh so uh again like would you like
to enroll into the digital marketing
program by P University uh so you can
see quick poll on your screen with two
quick options here
so whenever I speaking the polls are
moving so that is why just stop it so
folks are still basically uh sharing the
responses on the poll uh if you have any
more questions for our speaker today
related to digital marketing career or
the program please do let us know on the
Q&A box we'll be taking those uh pretty
soon after
this awesome let me just quickly end the
uh in 5 seconds now so 5 4 3 2 1 let me
just quickly end the poll for you folks
and uh thank you so much for sharing
your responses for the enrollment poll
here uh we would love to see in the
upcoming cohorts uh because we saw a lot
of folks basically who shared interest
towards enrollment so let me take you
through the enrollment step of the
program here so there are three simple
easy steps you need to follow uh you
need to submit an application to us at
ask us s.net I'll be putting that in the
chat on some up and um you need to
basically your application will be going
for review uh based on the eligibility
and PRC we have shared earlier and based
on that you'll be getting admissions
offer from C learning Consultants from c
will be reaching out to you based on uh
the response like in the upcoming poll
you know when do you plan to endroll
you'll be giving us and also you can
Avail the bonus offer with that as well
for attending this webinar so uh the
upcoming cohorts the classes start on
December 2nd this year and and the inity
class will be starting on November 9th
so that is the upcoming cohort for I
think few folks have asked you know when
is the next immediate uh you know go
they can join also uh the program fee
here for Indian cabinates is 1 lakh
1,999 INR including uh the GST uh and
for us candidates it is $3,000
USD uh I am aware that folks have joined
from different different uh countries
here it's not just us and India so what
I can do do is I can share the program
link for you to check out the program
fee in your own region uh so I think
someone has asked that as well in the q&
Box I'll just quickly share that so in
case you want to go through the program
curriculum in much more detail you can
also check out through this link and
also the program fee and the upcoming
coh for your own region as well so you
can check that out and as we have
mentioned that if you need any
assistance you can always contact us at
ask send on.net and also you can submit
an application as well in case you want
to end if you have not already answered
the PO so you can let us know there as
well so uh also folks just to let you
know that we have very limited seats per
C uh so we only take 25 to 30 folks per
C in order to make sure you're getting
all the attention that is required uh
while basically you are basically have
joined the program you're taking up this
course so uh so me based on that uh
we'll be basically taking up few Q&A
questions before we move on to the next
part of the session uh so as we can see
I think we answered a lot of queries
during the session so let me just browse
uh and quickly browse and see if you
have any questions new questions
here okay there were a lot of questions
for the website I think that is
something you already shared B I think
the
Kum okay I was answering some of them uh
via uh
just typing it in to just answering them
that way but if you have some
um if you have something that you want
to cover um someone do we learn YouTube
marketing too yes you do learn YouTube
marketing I think we um we spoke about
uh the 47 year old taking a break so we
answered that which AI tools are used in
Google ads so um AI is so when I say
that AI has been here um it's it's
basically the ability for that when they
say learning period in in Google ads
that learning period that they're
talking about is the ability for their
software to be able to learn where your
customers are and that is powered by AI
so when I see questions about Ai and
then AI taking over to chat GPT chat GPT
is the newest iteration of AI so either
one still has to be powered by a human
because it's a data model that has to be
fed so that's important to know and once
it learns like the behavior of your
customers then it is able to con uh
produce consistent results so that's
kind of how you answer that someone says
how do you do tagging of call to action
in Google analytics that question is a
little bit more Technical and difficult
to answer without seeing the site
however I know that Google has a
mechanis called think with Google I'm
going to type it directly to your
question think with Google and a lot of
those technical things that you have to
do to kind of maneuver through your
websites can be answered there um how
does digital marketing tie in with AI
how can we collaborate we answered that
one um how does AI how AI has
interference with digital marketing it
doesn't it works in conjunction with
digital marketing so again um all of you
guys that are interested but are
concerned about GPT taking over GPT is
just the newest iteration it's like a
fad uh before it was GPT there were like
just in general like social media
digital ads like there's always
something that comes down the pike in
this industry and being in this industry
for as long as I have there's always
something that comes to disrupt the
thing that came before it so think of it
as your iPhone cameras like you know
every year there's a phone that comes
out but then there's something with the
camera there's something with the
features or something like that that
comes out and this is more of a
feature um there are a lot of things in
digital marketing for the people who's
just starting out we already answered
that one resume tips on Creative
Marketing chat GPT that's my answer to
that chat GPT use chat gbt and that's
how you get the resume done and then
have somebody look over it so it doesn't
sound like a robot um where's the name
where is the name of the project I'll
answer that to you directly that is
acadium aum.com is it practical yes so
many of our instructors have been
trained to give practical analysis pract
practical exams so that's um that's
where that is email marketing there is
an elective that is dedicated directly
to email marketing and really again
where you have to focus on with
marketing this is why I said this is it
is psychology you have to understand the
psychology of your buyers what is most
important to them what is their pain
Point what causes them and triggers them
to purchase a product and you can think
just nominally about how you purchase
products what gets you to click so
definitely start there and then there's
a lot of platforms that actually kind of
show you what best works on their
platform I'm trying to answer them as
fast as I can Russia so what is your
yeah what is your advice on career field
to embark on at the moment my interest
is mainly social media marketing and
social engine optimization I would
assume that you found this webinar
Michael on um LinkedIn do a LinkedIn job
search within your area and also select
remote and see where those opportunities
lie and what type of experience I would
do like a filtered search from one to
two years and start there looking at the
type of qualities and the
classifications or qualifications that
they're looking for and refine your
skills and your skill sets based off of
that I work as a sales associate and
I've been thinking of getting into some
marketing skills to refine my skills my
sales skills would this be a waste of
time absolutely not because it focuses
on psychology as a matter of fact with
the centure I actually teach salespeople
how to basically sell Advertising
Solutions to potential advertisers so
essentially I have to understand
Marketing in order for them to teach
them how to have the talking points to
sell marketing so no it is not a waste
of time and in fact it's going to help
you to be a better
seller um is there an intership
opportunity at the end of the program
there are some I will divert to Russia
on those opportunities to prepare
because I think they are in certain
areas I don't think that every area has
this opportunity so I'll I'll take your
cue on
that okay I think we have answered all
of the questions here thank you so much
B for taking those questions
uh we are towards the end of the program
uh but as I mentioned earlier for folks
who have already shared their interest
towards enrollment and also uh basically
I have questions basically about you
know when is the basically the upcoming
next qu you know apart from the C I've
mentioned so folks who basically are
looking for next upcoming Cod which
starts on 2nd of December you can choose
the option immediately and uh the three
other options for folks who are still
thinking about it are not sure you know
when do you basically plan to start so
you can choose the options I think
within 3 months within 6 months or the
last one more than six months or now
would be something you know more
suitable for you so you have enough time
to think about you know uh when do you
plan to start so as you actually share
your responses on the poll here
basically when do you plan to enroll
into the program uh so I would suggest
that you can select more than six months
from now as well in case you're not
planning to join even within six months
because the bonus offer you'll be
getting for attending the webinar you
can Avail even after that as well so I
would recommend to choose that option in
case you are not prepared you know when
do you plan to
start so as I was speaking we have we
can see that folks have already started
sharing the responses here uh but I will
recommend few of the folks uh you know
who also have shared basically their
interest towards enrollment uh please
quickly go and share this with us so
this will give us an idea when exactly
to reach out to you with the admissions
offer letter uh for the per University's
postgraduate program and digital
marketing Also let's not forget the
bonus offer as well so for attending the
webinar so I think I'll just give 5
Seconds more for the poll here because
most of the folks have already share the
responses so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the
poll thank you so much folks for sharing
that with us we are towards the end of
the uh program here we basically are
ending it right on time so that's great
uh so B first of all would love to thank
you for taking the time out and taking
us to this free career Master Class
digal marketing careers in4 uh would you
like to see something to the audience
before we end the
session yeah I would just you know um
encourage everyone that you know this is
a really wonderful field to be in I have
been extremely fulfilled and happy over
the last 11 years being in this field
I've learned a ton there's a lot of
opportunities in growing it's definitely
not a field that's slowing down so all
of you who have that interest you are in
the right place and the best place to
start is to start by learning a lot of
people are saying you know I don't know
where to start where do I start start
with learning the basics and take it one
step at a time and you should be good
and then as you start to learn and grow
then you start to learn what you're
interested in and you
execute uh thank you so much B once
again we basically are getting a lot of
responses in the chat here from even the
audience here that they have basically
enjoyed the session was interesting
enlightening uh again like once again
thank you for this uh folks do let us
know in the chat if you have uh any any
comments or feedbacks and how did you
like the session for one here before
just take one minute for that before we
end the
session and also uh looking forward to
the upcoming uh cohart you know would
love to see you folks in the newcoming
cour of this
course yep absolutely I can't say 100%
certain but it's still going to be
great H yeah thank you so much F thank
you once again for being an amazing
active audience and once again thank you
so much bad for joining us and taking us
to the interesting career master class
in digital marketing so we are getting a
lot of positive responses in the chat so
that that means all good all good so
we'll be ending the session now I think
someone asked about the post webinar
survey so once I end the session now you
will be getting the post webinar survey
and you can basically quickly go and put
down your full name there in the
basically survey for if you want your
webinar certificate for the session uh
so basically whatever name you prefer to
be basically there in the webinar
certificate that will help us out so
please do let us know uh so again like
thank you so much thank you for so much
positive responses in the chat here for
the webinar and we'll be coming up with
more webinars uh you can basically check
out uh upcoming webinars uh you know but
simply we do this almost every day of
the week here and we have some
interesting webinars lined up for
November and December and uh you'll be
getting to see Bernard as well you know
in the next upcoming marketing session
as well so uh once again thank you so
much folks be ending the session now
have a good evening good afternoon good
morning wherever your name is thank
you
[Music]